d'un centre d'art à un entrepôt
logistique
trois heures après les premières frappes
russes qui ont visé l'ukraine le palais
des arts de lviv a changé de vocation à
la place des tableaux qui ornent ses
murs et des mélodique et résonner dans
sa salle de concert figurent désormais
ces boîtes où s'empilent chaussures
vêtements boîtes de conserves
médicaments tente sacs de couchage tout
ce qui peut être utile aux réfugiés et
aux déplacés qui quittent la région
c'est donc qu'ils viennent d'ukraine et
de partout en europe témoigne de la
grande solidarité avec le peuple
ukrainien
c'est vraiment incroyable et je suis
vraiment impressionné de voir à quel
point nous sommes unis en tant que pays
en tant que nation et je dirais même à
quel point nous sommes unis en tant
qu'europe c'est vraiment impressionnant
de voir comment la société s'est uni
c'est vraiment dommage que nous avons dû
payer un tel prix pour ça nous aidons
les gens c'est le moins que nous
puissions faire
je n'arrête pas de dire que chacun aime
son propre combat ici notre combat
ce combat les volontés à le mène ici
jour et nuit malgré le couvre-feu imposé
à lviv 24 heures sur 24 et 7 jours sur 7
ils se relaient sans relâche car les
besoins sont très importants
avec le déplacement de plus de 2
millions d'ukrainiens de chez eux